so you do I don't know what you would
call them but like integrated ads in
your videos and you do I would say
masterfully it's like part of the video
you're talking about brand deals brand
deals is that what you would call that
yep so it's a brand deal it's part of
the video
it's still really exciting to watch and
yet there's a plug for the brand in
general just brand deals since you
brought it up uh integrating them well I
think that's something a lot of creators
don't do like they'll just do a brand
deal out of the blue they'll just be
filming a video and then around the
three minute Mark just start talking
about a random company yeah and you I
feel like if you don't want viewers to
click away and you want people to not
get pissed off and call you to sell out
you got to find a way to integrate into
content and ideally use the money in the
video to make it better like as the
easiest thing you do when you do a brand
deal is just tell people how you're
using money from the brand deal to make
your content better and if you do that
like no one cares now they're supporting
you for it and you go from being a
sellout to like oh I'm doing this to
make better videos for you guys you know
I don't know if you can share but with
those Brands when you have discussions
with them are they strict about how long
you need to be talking about it or is it
more about their leaving control to you
about the artistic element of it the
problem is the the ones who don't give
us the artistic element we just don't
really work with anymore
because it's just you know we get 100
million views of video now and I can
confidently say I know how to entertain
them and convert them better than these
random Brands so uh yeah if they don't
give us that freedom I just won't work
with them so you have that leverage but
for smaller creators it's a lot harder
yeah and they're they're gonna just say
45 seconds here's what you say take it
or leave it and it's like pretty brutal
because I think just in general
if Brands were more accommodating to let
creators tell their story onto Brandon
talk about the brand in a way that felt
a little more natural I I think it'd be
less cringe it people would be less
likely to go and you know tough times
tap Skip and uh obviously it would
convert better but they're just so
afraid and they want this standardized
thing say these words and 45 seconds
right here at this three minute Mark
yeah I often think about how to resist
that you just don't do them though right
not on YouTube right on audio I do ads
in the very beginning and I say you can
skip them if you want
um but Grant loves that I don't like the
point is they
so the funny thing about podcasts is
different than YouTube videos podcast
people actually do listen to ads a lot
because they it's slower paced and they
like the the Creator voice like talking
about the thing
um but in general I just don't believe
you should be talking about a thing for
a minute exactly and that's going to be
effective I want to see the data for
that I think what's much more effective
is the way you do ads which is like
integrated into the content like put a
lot of effort into making a part of that
like doing the brand deals and
I just it's difficult
to have that conversation it's like a
very
strenuous conversation you have to have
with with Brands you have to each one at
a time and I just wish there was more of
a culture to say like the quality of the
ad read matters a lot more than the uh
like the silly parameters like the
timing of it